[Music]
all right so we've already
released the video about how uh
giuliani's releasing
a lot of crazy photos of hunter biden
and whatnot
on the same day he started releasing
biden stuff
oh giuliani himself released his
own youtube video a podcast video
that happened to be unedited for
whatever reasons they just didn't edit
out the very end of the podcast
and after the podcast was done the
interview was done
you know they're you know they're
they're taking off the mics or whatever
but there's still audio rolling
the video camera's still rolling so the
angle is a little weird
in this little outtake but they left it
in the at in the in the full upload
and this is what he had to say oh no
what the [ __ ]
oh i'm so cute i can't wait this is the
best content right here
this this is the scale it's like nba
this is my favorite [ __ ] oh yeah
you're getting too upset about this oh
before before
yeah so he's speaking to a girl named
janie
zirkel or jane zirkel and i i looked her
up
uh and she is a conservative
uh like she's a high school student
conservative uh
uh like pro-trump person and she has a
youtube channel and everything's been
private
since this thing went viral oh [ __ ] so
she's hiding out now and she's pretty
much a kid then she's a
she's a kid i think she's like assisting
the campaign like she's like an
assistant office assistant yeah exactly
and she's
in this clip she's showing uh giuliani
like a picture of her
a picture we don't see the picture we
don't know what the picture is
we could speculate yeah and this is what
he had to say and who's recording this
oh this is at the end of the podcast
this is a podcast you can splice it off
at the end
yeah they didn't cut it out yeah so
someone the editor [ __ ] up
and this is what he said or what
didn't [ __ ] up true it's intentional oh
my goodness so much scary stuff these
days
jamie you're getting too upset about
this you're going to be the most famous
model in in
in china oh give me a change
what would you like to have for dinner
james circle pick up james
australia i want jake zuckerberg to come
picture james circle no one but james
what the [ __ ] is he doing he was just
imitating a chinese guy oh
i didn't get it let's see let's see
let's see let's see let's see all right
wait what
very little context i've been i scoured
the internet trying to find more
context is he pretending to be chinese i
think
he's saying her name jane you're gonna
be the biggest model in china
and then he started imitating a chinese
person's name oh
cool picture i want jane basically i
want a photo with james circle
you are a model and i want a photo with
you that's basically what he's
insinuating
gen circle circle circle circle
i don't know what the [ __ ] he was saying
are you surprised he talks like that
no no i'm just growing he imitates
chinese people like that yeah
like his his asian accent's not very
good i expect
not very good if you're gonna mock asian
people who have a better accent
i expect all old people to do those lame
jokes yeah
not that it's okay but i just expect all
people of his age
that's funny that's it's stupid yeah
it's just it's
gross fruity giuliani dude
yeah so this is a picture of jane's jane
jane james circle no it's a jade sucker
jade soco yeah yeah and oh yeah so sorry
i opened up the wrong way again
she made the news yeah she made the news
yeah so this is her she's like
fresh out of high school i think and
then this is yeah her on the news
channel
uh trump's supporting high schooler
hounded out of her
dc high school so she she got canceled
out of her own high school why what is
she being a trump supporter
being a trump supporter she's she goes
to high school yeah she's in dc
so she was like secretly a supporter or
something
i i well i think when she fully came out
and started
you know like maybe she wants to be in
politics yeah
maybe she wants to be in politics she's
in the dc area you know and if if she
has conservative views
you know i think her acts is to get on
to the stupidest
i'm saying like in her high school they
didn't know she was conservative so now
all of a sudden they're like oh
we gotta bully her because she is yeah
maybe weird
i mean i don't think people go around go
around like stating their
their their political views all the time
so i guess i mean if she's like that
close to the campaign
like i would imagine she's like putting
it on her social media like she's
passionate about it or whatever it is
that's what i'm trying to get she's
wearing maga hats to school probably
yeah i don't know i i'm having i mean
looking up for uh photos of her it
doesn't seem like she's ever taken a
photo with
a mega hat you said i know uh you said
she has a youtube channel
yeah and i i can't find it yeah you said
you said that
they got private after this went viral
but like what
what like triggered the attack on her
for ruby
giuliani trying to be chinese i don't
know because
that's gross when i first found this
when i first found this article she did
have tweets that were
public still and then when i went back
to go
look for pictures of her to show you
guys here yeah i noticed her twitter is
now
locked uh protected and i can't access
anything anymore
so i have a feeling it was based on that
video getting out and we and that oh
that youtube video is also private now
as well
so yeah that's what's happening there
podcasts about do you know uh they were
interviewing
um some guy were they asking each other
their favorite chinese food was
giant circle dumpling you know be so
funny if she was like
she was like you know i got this
modeling contract in china
and then like these are the photos and
then he's like oh you're going to be
famous out there
jane sucker jane but the fact that he
kept
going and like did this beating the joke
for so long i was like
bro you are like that lame ass uncle
that repeats the same [ __ ] thing over
and over
and until somebody actually goes haha
gives you a [ __ ] pity
i know i thought i don't think anyone
actually hurt him i don't think
i don't think yeah he's senile dude he's
like joking by himself because he thinks
he's so [ __ ] [ __ ] that pool is
crazy as [ __ ]
too yeah that dude is nuts man
dude yeah i think it's just [ __ ]
ironic the day he
tries to like uh start a smear campaign
against the democratic drama dude
this [ __ ] happens to him at his own
like he does it to himself what is the
uh
what does the public think about this i
don't know nobody really likes rudy
giuliani right let's find out
i remember ever since he was the mayor
yeah the city of new york because they
[ __ ] clown on that dude so hard they
do not like him
i don't really know if anyone likes
leaders
that's not true like the canadian prime
minister or not
yeah but he's fine though he's fine for
the beginning part
he was really loved but then after they
don't like him anymore
i don't know david newsom is kind of
fine but no one likes him yeah but he's
kind of a dick though you know
yeah i mean did you did you hear about
his recent thing where you have to put
on a mask in between bites
yeah that's a stupid hat and who's gonna
enforce that
cuckoo like on the galvan newsome
website
in between bites in [ __ ] between
they're suggesting
that you have your mask on at a
restaurant and then you take it off
and then you have a bite you put it back
on to chew but what if you're eating a
noodle and the bite is really long
you put it on every every city i go you
put the noodle on you put it back and
then the
noodle comes in from the side every city
i go to in la
there's always um a tent out that says
impeach or what is it called
recall gavin newsom damn and like in
monterey park
it's like an old chinese lady has having
like um petitions out there
i saw one in uh i forgot i saw one in
pasadena
saw one in like highland park there
people are very upset with gavin news on
both sides i think of course across the
board yeah no one really likes him yeah
everyone's kind of done with it he's
still fine though he's still fine he's
still handsome you need to be a bottle
he looks he reminds me of american
psycho a little bit yeah he's a silver
fox that guy
yeah isn't he related to somebody in
pelosi yeah like a like a grand
nephew or something no she's kind of
fine too shut up
that's [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
like a regular white dude like this is
the still the style
dude i mean he has very good bone
structure that's true it's different
it's difficult
sexier or if you go on his only fans
page
yeah you see way better stuff
i feel like gavin newsom will like this
photo oh no no that's not that's not
very clear
i think gavin newsom will like this
photo of himself
fine her neck that's like classic yeah
he's kind of handsome
dimples are my weaknesses he does look
like he do find him attractive he only
got one american psycho style
you know when um [ __ ] goes down where
like let's say like um politicians might
say racist [ __ ]
or like when trump's was like with the
kung flu and all that stuff right
like um i think within the asian
community there are different schools of
thought some people think
no matter what we got to keep all of
that [ __ ] accountable because nobody in
power
should make those racist jokes whereas
like
i'm kind of like 50 50 because my
comedian hat comes on
and then i'm just kind of like looking
at the intention and how they're trying
to execute it
versus like looking at it as a citizen
who wants to keep my politician
like more accountable squeaky clean
more like a better representative of the
state you know
versus like i mean that that he's doing
that stupid
lame uncle [ __ ] you know like yeah it's
like man come on dude that's a stupid
old joke
for me i think it depends on like the
platform because i've seen like
the most polite uh and well-mannered
dads at their son's basketball game
and they say the crazy issue like [ __ ]
you ref are you [ __ ] blind
yeah and i'm like oh [ __ ] i guess that's
okay here
and then after it's like hey bartow's a
good game wasn't it yeah
so i just think like if you're in your
own living room or your own backyard
you could say it's like sex talk right
like if you guys want to say some crazy
dirty [ __ ] to each other in the middle
of the bedroom that's okay that's like
what
i don't know like oh you are soft
i'm soft too let's get some dirty talk
yeah what
you know i think that's okay and then
like so i think it depends on how it's
channel i think when that stuff starts
leaking out
then it gets scary so like technically
since like the podcast was done yeah you
know what i mean they caught him at a
private moment so when it's [ __ ] like
this where there's like private moment
moments being leaked
i have a little bit more like uh
leniency
leniency because i'm like the situation
circumstantial
yeah yeah yeah i agree because like with
the melania tapes that came out i was
just like
i mean she was just expressing her
frustration i don't get it i think the
fear
for like let's say um if uh you know in
the asian community would be like
well let's say this guy is a closet
racist toward asians right
and we we found this leak and then we go
well
is he gonna is that gonna reflect in the
way he governs
because if he is uh you know like a
closet racist against asians
then it's like oh [ __ ] he might
he might do [ __ ] sinister to the
community that we don't even know about
this whole time like he has his face of
like
yeah i'm all about all people and
whatever so i think as a politician
we have to hold them by a different
standard versus
uh some old dude that just says stupid
[ __ ] yeah
yeah because whether we like it or not
he does have power and he doesn't have
he does it can affect the lives of
the asian american community so i don't
know and
you can't attack somebody without also
you know
having to or being attacked yourself in
in a certain way so it's like because
he's already like you know like you said
put somebody else on blast
i think it's fair game yeah fair game
dude karma [ __ ]
if you're releasing pictures of a guy
with a crack pipe in his mouth
come on dude this ain't this ain't
nothing for you
you're doing a shitty ass chinese accent
has he made any comments about them no
he's hush-hush about this [ __ ]
dude this is like it's juicy drama [ __ ]
this is what we should start doing any
picture we find of rudy giuliani we just
photoshop a crack piping
start a meme and then and then our
thought bulbous says uh what's her name
yeah jane circle jane circus i'm poor
girl
dammit oh what does she do she'll be
fine no she's she's just a kid yeah
she'll be fine she got 18
000 followers she could be traumatized
imagine being like 17 or 8 people
saying her name like that james circle
it's all chinese people though yeah yeah
but then she's like rudy was wrong okay
she's like all right why are you guys
saying this like that like could you
just like see
yeah people are gonna forget about it
that's that's our response we go up
there we're like oh
picture picture and then she's like oh
okay you wanna take that poor girl
[Music]
[Music]
you